patient because of trials at that time
had not recruited
too many elderly people but that said a
very important step forward
with the astrazeneca oxford vaccine as
you know that
vaccine is in phase 3 trial here in the
us we have almost
totally completed the recruitment of
that trial we have twenty nine thousand
seven seven hundred subjects
in the study out of the about thirty
thousand of our plant
and uh uh this will
start to accrue we project if everything
goes
well that
readouts and emergency use authorization
may be granted somewhere early in
april and by that time uh uh
several tens of millions of doses of
this vaccine will have been manufactured
at uh emergent uh
and and will have been stopped by it and
therefore
will be available for use if the data
support
its approval as has just been the case
with the
mhra so an important progress this week
in fact this day the second important
point is the novabax vaccine
the novorax vaccine has started
phase three trials on the 27th we
already have
1 000 subjects recruited in the state
participating in the trial have already
been activated and are recruiting
the trial is being conducted currently
in the us and in mexico
and may also include
and potentially brazil if we are able to
bring these countries
into the tribe fast enough it's very
important
that we recruit subjects here in the us
but also
outside of the u.s because we project
that there will be some challenges
having subjects at risk particularly the
elderly
the healthcare workers and people with
common abilities participating into the
trial
when there is uh the moderna and the
fiber
and potentially over time the janssen's
vaccines uh
available for use and immunization uh in
mass
the third point uh concern so that's a
great progress with the nova back and as
you know novellax is
the first protein vaccine to progress
it's in fact the fifth
out of six vaccines in our portfolio
that's progressing into phase three
trials
uh about nine months after starting this
uh
endeavor eight months and a half
the next program is the j j jensen's
vaccine
you know we announced last week that the
phase 3 trial recruitment
has been completed and we are very
diligently working
with the company and with the regulators
we feel more and more confident
that readout of efficacy will take place
during the month of january
and very likely that an eoa submission
will take place during the month of uh
january
so within within the next four weeks and
uh hopefully
an approval may be reached uh in the
first half of the month
of february and we are also working
hard with the company and the fda to
further accelerate
vaccine doses availability during the
month
of february uh i think it can be uh
quite a game changer
we are hopeful that this vaccine which
is a one-shot vaccine
will have equivalent efficacy to uh
those of uh moderna and pfizer
uh we'll comment on that uh once we have
the data
that is i'd like to attract your
attention on on the confidence intervals
that are around each one of the members
of fxc
for pfizer and moderna 95 with a
confidence interval between 89 and 100
meaning if we were to repeat these
studies with the same vaccine
efficacy would come anywhere between 89
and 100 percent the uh
next point to raise your attention is uh
on modern and pfizer we continue to have
a good
supply into the system and the output of
vaccine closes
uh general purina my colleague and
partner will of course
brief you more thoroughly on that what i
want to say is with the modern vaccine
we really really would like to encourage
more
adolescents to participate in the
clinical trial that's ongoing
trial between the age of 12 and the
age of 18. we only have 22 subjects
recruited in the study we understand
that it's a little bit of a challenge
given the holiday season
but after the holidays it i think it's
really important
for more adolescents to participate in
this clinical trial this is a highly
effective and very safe vaccine
and by participating in the trial we
will
be able to accelerate the approval of
this vaccine next to the physical
vaccine
for use in this younger population i
think it's very important to do
we're also continuing to work with the
company and with the fda
on potentially using a lower dose in
to those uh immunization to increase the
capacity
faster this is of course only relevant
if it can be done
on a very short-term basis uh
continuing progress with the sanofi
vaccine the other protein-based vaccine
we are now looking at starting the phase
2b program as per
some of his press release hopefully by
the middle of the month
of february on the therapeutic side of
things
we have more data on usage of the
monoclonal antibodies we raise the
challenge
that not enough of the antibody doses
available in hospitals
are actually being used so there's good
news and less good news the good news is
there is a progression week a week
on the usage going
from 10 last week to 20 this week the
less good news it's
only 20 and we really need to continue
to work hard
on the various reasons that are very
very
pragmatic reasons why usage is
more limited it's very important that we
progress there
i will stop there and pass on to uh
general program will
now brief you and then you'll be happy
to take your questions thank you
great thanks dr slowly um for everybody
happy holidays and thanks for being with
us again this week
uh as we try to keep you updated uh with
everything that we know that's going on
so
this week you know we've provided
jurisdictions with the final allocations
of doses available that means uh by
tomorrow night
uh all the jurisdictions will be able to
place orders for up to 20 million doses
of vaccine which has been
collective uh over the last uh two weeks
plus since
the first eua by pfizer and then
following eua by moderna
we are really doing well uh in my
opinion in the
distribution over 14 million doses of
vaccine have been distributed to date
and every day we push more vaccine i'll
talk about that
as we go forward in fact this week we
started
not only pushing first dose vaccine but
we started pushing
second dose vaccine for the pfizer
vaccine
as uh people who received the first dose
around 4 january will start to be
eligible for the second dose
we wanted to sure ensure that the
vaccine was available
to all you know the cadence uh for uh
our execution is really coming into
good posture uh we're allocating to the
states on tuesday
states are available to order off the
allocations
on thursday we're picking and packing
supplies to ensure it can be delivered
by the following week really remarkable
effort by the collective group of
professionals the men and women
who have been working tirelessly from
pfizer moderna mckesson ups
and fedex as they execute this
uh every day and they are the ones that
are executing the movement of the
vaccine
uh i'd be remiss if i did not highlight
the great work
uh by the state and local governments
as they do the planning and they
determine the allocation at the state
levels
uh in the final administration uh i
think has
been an incredible task so i just would
like to take a minute as we close out
this year
to kind of think about where we've been
over the last
seven and a half plus months since uh dr
slowly and i
were notified uh and you know presented
at the rose garden uh in may
so what we've done we've developed two
safe and effective vaccines now for
use authorized for use to the american
people
we've scaled up manufacturing capacity
in some cases
building new brick and mortar from the
ground up we've issued
18 defense production act ratings
which allows us to prioritize materials
supplies and equipment essential to the
u.s government contracts
it puts them at the front of the line
hired and trained new staff
and embedded logisticians and supply
chain experts
in all the manufacturing facilities as
we move forward
we developed and launched a new data
system that connects
hundreds of existing systems at the
state and local level
to allow us to have visibility so that
we can see ourselves across the entire
united states
we've executed extensive planning
starting with the cdc putting out their
playbook in september
and then extensive coordinations with
the state health officials
every day every week and every month
since and it continues
as we go forward we dedicated regional
planning teams that are
constantly available 24 hours a day
seven days a week
at the cdc in support of the state and
local governments
we provided it specialists to help
all the jurisdictions to see themselves
so that they understand
exactly where everything is at a single
point of time
they can plan and direct accordingly
we developed a program we the cdc
really developed a magnificent program
to
uh in collaboration with cvs and
walgreens
to go to all of our long-term health
care facilities
and administer vaccine to really one of
the two top priorities
the elderly living in these homes over
906
clinics conducted to date as we ramp up
to 4
000 a week so really remarkable tasks
we've inked a partnership with 19
pharmacy
chains to ensure as we go from stage 1a
to 1b
that we can expand the capacity of
distribution
throughout the country which gives
everybody greater access to the vaccine
in each state as directed by the
governors
and the state health officials we funded
distribution for vaccines alongside of
ancillary kits to ensure that those
things were there
when they were needed and we did this
early on
so that we had the right distribution
mechanisms
and the right ancillary kits to be
distributed with the vaccine
and we provided dry ice to everybody
that wants it on the first replenishment
for all pfizer vaccines
we cut through the red tape right to
ensure
all the vaccines provided to americans
will be free of
charge and finally as i started out with
we've allocated and will be available
for final ordering 20 million doses by
this thursday
distributed more than 14 million doses
of vaccine to over 10
800 locations and we
have administered over two million doses
in the last two weeks really a
remarkable feat
and everybody collectively should be
very proud
right the federal government industry
academia
state and local governments it has been
a whole
of america approach as we work
every day to make sure that the vaccine
gets to where it needs to be
we are out checking yesterday i was able
to go visit two hospitals
in the local area one in d.c and one up
in maryland
and i just saw remarkably dedicated
staffs
who were engaged who understood the
vaccines
under their care who were involved in
making sure that they were executing
administration the right way to ensure
that it's effectively used to the
priorities
of the governors in implementation i was
highly impressed
remarkably dedicated people working
every day
as they go through this they've done
this over the last two weeks
through holidays uh trying to give
everybody
some time off after a long year of
fighting the virus
as they're working through the
administration of the vaccine
to ensure that everybody gets it at a
different time and not
everybody at one time and then they've
worked through
three major snowstorms in the last two
weeks
and still really a remarkable job so
i just want to applaud everybody's
efforts
collectively over as we work through the
vaccines
for the last seven and a half months
vaccines and therapeutics
our responsibility is to ensure that we
are delivering
or developing manufacturing and
delivering
safe and effective vaccines and
therapeutics to the american people
and so i just i'm just thrilled to be a
part of this
and i'm excited about all the
collaboration
and great work that everybody's done to
date
thank you thank you to you both
moderator will now open it up for
questions as a reminder please state
your name and outlets
and please keep your questions as short
as possible so we can get to as many as
we can
thank you as a reminder if you'd like to
ask a question please press
star one unmute your phone record your
name and your outlet clearly
your name and outlet are required to
introduce your question if you need to
withdraw your question press star two
again to ask a question please press
star one
we'll go ahead and begin with sarah
orman from politico
mr your line is now open hi thank you
this is sarah overmall from politico um
dr sewer i wanted to ask or you were
breaking up a little bit in the
beginning when you were talking about
the astrazeneca vaccine
were you saying that you felt the
british approval was premature
or i mean since the u.s approval will be
like you said months
uh later how are you swearing those two
things and then um
general turner i know that hhs said
yesterday that there's some lag in the
cdc numbers for vaccination rates
so what's the disparity there like what
how much of a lag is there and what are
the real numbers
yeah so uh i hope i hope you can hear me
okay
mhra is a science-based
highly well-skilled regulatory agency
and therefore i am not raising any
question
as to the decision that
they have made having said that
the requirements and the decision
process
as we have built it here in the us is
what i can really comment on and what i
know
from within and uh that was the sense of
my comments the date of april
for an emergency use authorization is
based on completion of the phase three
trial that's being run here in the u.s
where we understand the clinical trial
material that was used
how and where it was manufactured we
understand that immunization was
has happened all the time according to a
given those
in the right schedule and the safety
database
is being uh analyzed and and generated
exactly as has been the case for the
other trials
i have no doubt that the vaccine is very
effective against severe disease and is
effective
in the population where it was tested i
for me the biggest question mark frankly
is efficacy in the elderly population
that needs to be
further documented just because there
were not enough cases
in the elderly because there were not
enough elderly subjects included in the
trial
early on i know that there will be
further analysis of the uk and brazil
trials
that may actually give an information
about that as far as the american people
are concerned
i think it's important that we are able
to say one vaccine has 95 percent
efficacy
another vaccine has x percent whatever
is that number
we need a clear and concrete number more
than a
a number that is uh you know accumulated
by
by adding together different
trials with different schedules and and
and uh different material
so no criticism but more focus on how
we are doing it and it will be of course
an fda decision
to decide whether to consider also
approval of the basis of the
data that mhra has
used or not i do want to add one thing
as i have the microphone open
just in to join general purna in
banking and acknowledging the work of
the tens of thousands of people that are
involved in
the development manufacture supply
of the vaccine and administration of the
vaccine
and with the general we have towards so
many
agencies in the various states and
health agencies
to discuss the rollout of the vaccine
and the administration of the vaccine
we have engaged with all the players and
all the parties involved
in this process and heard their input on
how we can
optimize and maximize the usage of the
vaccine doses
available we committed to have 20
million doses distributed
to the us population and that's the
number as an alterna
i said that will be actually available
to take from
uh as of tomorrow and 40 million dollars
are
already where they should be
administered
we have heard and agree that 2.1 million
and frankly i don't
know the exact last number uh
it's in the system uh somewhere there is
a lag in how
the numbers are computed but surely it's
a number that is smaller
than the 14 million doses that are out
there already
available for use we agree that that
number
is lower than what we hoped for we
philosophically as we have always done
do not spend too much time
describing a challenge we then very
quickly move
to addressing the challenge and as we
have always done we would like to invite
anybody that has energy to participate
and help us further improve
administration of the vaccine
to come to the table put your sleeves up
and come help us
with specific ideas we know that it
should be better
and we're working hard to make it better
so we welcome really
very much any input but it needs to be
specific
and uh actionable thank you general
fernando i don't know if you would like
to add something
i'm in full support of what you just
said dr slowly uh
at the end there accordingly i would
also say
uh i'm i'm working personally on
a 72 to 96 hour lag
uh that data will tighten up as we uh
you know the systems and reporting
becomes
more regular and routine uh and we'll
adjust
you know that lag as we gain more data
but we absolutely are are advocates
of higher uptake um and i have
a lot of confidence personally that the
states uh at the at the state level
and local levels are working this
aggressively
especially as they execute you know one
a
priority with um first line medical
uh persons and then long-term health
care facilities
two very difficult challenging groups
but the right groups and so i am
confident that everybody's working it
um the right way to make sure that the
vaccines are most effective
in those groups next question please
our next question comes from angelica
lovito from bloomberg
your line is now open hello so
during last week's briefing you
mentioned that the federal government
has the ability to help the state and
local governments
administer these vaccines faster so what
exactly are you doing and
will you need to readjust those plans
given that
just a fraction of the doses distributed
are actually being administered
so we always always have to continue to
assess and adjust i mean that's what we
do
all the time in life right we just don't
keep
walking straight ahead if things aren't
going where we need
so we assess and we and we continue to
make adjustments
uh as dr salawi just said and
i'm going to add on and so you know what
have we done we've worked hard to make
sure the long-term health care
facilities
were ready to be implemented with the
great partnership of cvs and walgreens
uh in the states and i think you know
that is going to be a very
very sound program that in years to come
uh
will be used as a model second uh as
more vaccine becomes available
and we do see you know very good steady
drum beat
of our vaccine coming off the
manufacturing and fill finish line
then we'll be able to expand
distribution to through the local brick
and mortar pharmacy
change the 19 that i talked about
we want to enable the governor's plans
uh to their priorities
and we think uh adding them right
to the distribution matrix right
through the provider agreements will
expand
capability and capacity of distribution
throughout the entire country
there's over 70 000 pharmacies
already enrolled to do this and so as
vaccine becomes available
states determined distribution
priorities
i visualize as early as uh 8
january between 8 and 15 january
the expansion to their utilization will
greatly increase access of vaccine to
the american
people and then we're just going to
continue on right
every every day we have to assess every
day we have to
keep pushing forward to ensure safe and
effective vaccines
are available to the american people
thank you next question
next question my next question comes
from lauren niergaard from the
associated press your line is now open
hi thank you um can you talk a little
bit more about
the um the decision by britain today
to actually allow a longer lag between
first dose and second dose
is that something that scientifically
makes sense and is that something that
the u.s
might consider in trying to push out
more first doses i know you all have
been very careful to say you're going to
hold back and reserve the second dose
for everyone who got a first dose so
that there was no lag time
so uh yes scientifically
uh we and others have done experiments
when i say we
in my previous life with other vaccines
have shown that if you space the time
between two vaccine doses
zero and one month zero two months zero
six months
you increase immune response after the
second dose
what i said each time when i spoke about
that
is to say it really is important to have
in mind
the level of transmission of the
pathogen that's happening
in the population at that stage because
efficacy after the first dose
may be a challenge either the point
efficacy so in the case of pfizer and
moderna
it's very high as of day 14 but we don't
know how
long it stays so it's very important to
acknowledge that we are in the
dark there in working space and in the
case
of the az vaccine the efficacy that's
been described
in a very small subpopulation in the
tribe that has received the space
period of time with the standard dose is
about 50 so one will need to just be
very clear in the communication
and it will depend what alternatives you
have in your portfolio vaccines
whether it is worth protecting at 95
percent
those most impacted by the disease very
quickly
or whether it's worth immunizing the
broader population
with the vaccine at 50 efficacy and that
is only relevant again
if vaccine doses as are available
for very widespread use into the
population
my understanding in the publications
is that the uk has 2 million doses of
vaccine available
for news as of now the number of doses
of vaccine will become
larger as time goes by
so i think this addresses your question
it's an important one but it's very
important
i think to use a vaccine based on how
you have studied it
for me the biggest concern if we were to
extend the time period between the first
and second dose
is what happens to persistence of
protection
if we expand that period of time it
probably
could go down and if it goes down in
what way does it go down does it go down
in a way that's it's simply less
efficacious or
when we have some individuals that may
have more severe disease
or things like that you know i would
really advise
not to do something that we have no
characterization of
and in the case of astrozoic and mhra
there is limited set of data but at
least there is some limited
data there too nothing wrong is
happening but efficacy is moderate at 50
thank you thank you next question please
the next question comes from rebecca
robbins from the new york times miss
robin your line is open
hello thank you for taking my question i
was hoping you could speak
to the main factors that are driving
the slower than expected uptake of
vaccines
specifically the the percentage
administered compared to the percentage
distributed
i know you'd mentioned the lag in
reporting but i was hoping to hear
if you had a read on the other factors
on the ground level that are influencing
this lag
so you know we're still we're still
gathering data the cdc is working
diligently on that
as they work with the states i do know
that
reporting has been really remarkable
in its clarity to them and they're
assessing and working through the
details i know
there's an extensive amount of
collaboration going on between the cdc
regional coordinators and each of the
jurisdictions
and states accordingly to have greater
specificity at this time
after two weeks i i don't think would be
appropriate i
do believe uh has been reported to me
is that uh vaccine allocations or uptake
usually
starts out a little slow uh and then it
then it
increases exponentially uh and very
rapidly
you know take take into effect one
that you know the pfizer vaccine came
out one week before the modern vaccine
essentially it's been just 12 days
there's two holidays
there's been three major snowstorms
there is everybody working through
you know how to do the notification how
to make sure we're administering it the
right way
how to ensure that it stays in
accordance with the cold chain
there's numerous factors and here's what
i have confidence in every day
everybody gets better and i believe that
uptake will increase significantly as we
go forward
thank you thank you next question please
our next question comes from ann searty
from abc news your line is now open
hi thank you for taking my question just
um to build on that
uh based on what you've seen in the past
15 days does any of this adjust your
timeline that the broader public
would have access to these vaccines by
april
well in terms of vaccine doses
available manufactured approved for use
there is no reason to believe there will
be any change uh
we still believe of course we know that
the modern and the 500 vaccines
are approved are highly effective are
being manufactured
as per plan we have planned 20 million
doses
by the end of the year they are there
there you know our plans continue to be
the same
i have each time cautioned that
manufacturing a vaccine is very complex
and therefore
at some point there could be hiccups but
there's
none at this stage and therefore we will
continue to have enough vaccine doses to
go through the atrocious population
and start to immunize particularly as we
signed the options with both models
and pfizer to acquire another hundred
million dollars from each
to make vaccine available and immunize
the general population
in terms of vaccine those availability
and capacity to distribute it and
in addition i remain very confident that
the jansen's vaccine
will be available probably in the month
of february
and remember that the az vaccine based
on on the trials running here in the us
may become available
in the month of april and so could the
the the vaccine
uh from nova back that has just started
uh its phase three trials
so from a from an availability
standpoint
uh there is there is no knowledge
from an administration standpoint i
concur general perna that
you know there's there's a learning
curve into the system
and we're going through it particularly
a number of days have
been quote unquote lost because of the
holy days or snowstorms
or we're learning and we'll continue to
learn and continue to listen
and uh seek input specific input from
others
to help further accelerate the uptake i
think as
people see in the broad population these
vaccines are safe
people will again you know come
forward more for uh vaccination as
vaccines become
available in pharmacies i think it will
become more straightforward
to go to a pharmacy and be immunized so
i expect
that things will move back
quickly what we should be looking at is
the rate
of acceleration over the coming weeks
and i hope
it will be in the right direction
thank you moderator we have time for two
more questions
understood the first of two is going to
be isaac stanley becker from washington
post
sir your line is open hi thanks for
doing the briefing and happy holidays i
wonder if i can ask just a couple
really quick questions one is that when
you said
that 14 million doses have been
distributed that's
somewhat more than the cdc tracker is
showing you have also an updated sense
beyond the 2.1
doses administered whether that already
is is somewhat greater over what the cdc
tracker that hasn't been updated since
monday is showing and then secondly in
terms of long-term care facilities
generally you mentioned last week that i
believe
12 states had initiated that program in
those facilities and that 13
additional states were expected to do so
this week was that the case in terms of
those 13
and do you have a sense of you know next
week or the week after
how many more may initiate that
so to your first question 14 million
doses
uh have been distributed uh there
literally may be some doses on the road
right now
as i speak um but i feel uh very
confident
that 14 million doses is what's being
distributed
to the american people reference the
jurisdictions
we did last week 14 states did 906
facilities this week 52
of 55 jurisdictions have been enrolled
in the process and they're scheduled to
do 4
000 clinics uh this week alone
uh which is why i believe the drum beat
will occur
the same way as we go forward we are
enacting
you know we're enabling the state's
plans
it's really important that the prior
coordination with each facility is done
so that we have the right administration
done at the right levels
and then we have the appropriate amount
of vaccine available so
depending on those two variables i feel
confident
that we can keep a pace of 4 000
uh clinics uh a week over
thank you thank you moderator one final
question
our last question comes from elizabeth
wiest from usa today
ma'am your line is open
hey was i couldn't tell was that my name
yes ma'am oh good hi this is elizabeth
wiese thanks for taking my call
i i wanted to ask how much of
the disconnect is the holdback of
vaccine for the long-term care
facilities because as i understand it
states that are part of that long-term
care facility program
have to hold back up they have to have
at least
half of the necessary vaccine
in house before they can launch but it's
a little murky to me can you give
clarity on that
so what we want to do is make sure that
the appropriate amount of vaccines
available so that when
cvs and walgreens coordinate times for
the clinics
that we are able to do everybody inside
of the facility both both the elderly
as well as those caring for them and so
really important
as we ramp up the total execution
that the vaccine's available so yes that
does contribute to part of the lag
and it could be a good significant
number a couple hundred million
uh for sure uh as we go forward because
we're working these uh every day as i
said
and every day they'll they don't get
registered until the vaccine gets
administered
uh and so it's a great point that you're
bringing up and
clearly could be part of you know the
lag in the numbers
so more to follow on that if i could
while i have the mic open i i made a mis
quote earlier a questioning i
said that there would be 70 000
pharmacies available
as we expand availability industry or
distribution for greater availability
really we have 70 000 providers enrolled
uh you know which includes hospitals
doctors offices
and pharmacies we have 40 000 pharmacies
enrolled and i just wanted to clarify
that for the record
thank you thank you general perna thank
you dr sally
again follow-up questions can be sent to
media hhs.gov
and with that i'll hand it over to the
operator to finish out the call thank
you all happy new year
[Music]
you